all right the balloon is gone in
February the U.S shot down a suspected
Chinese spy balloon and three
unidentified flying objects over North
American airspace though these Airborne
objects might seem like they came out of
nowhere surveillance balloons have
actually been around for centuries
here's a look at the history of spy
balloons what's been used in the past
and why countries are still using them
today
the first recorded use of balloons for
spying dates back to 1794 when the
French experimented with hydrogen-filled
balloons during the French Revolutionary
Wars
the Battle of larousse was the first
battle assisted by aerial observation
about 60 years later balloons made their
debut in the U.S where the Union and
Confederate armies used them for aerial
reconnaissance during the American Civil
War these would normally be Tethered to
the ground the technology was
essentially the human eye possibly aided
with some binoculars one of the primary
uses early in the war was just to see
where enemy camps were where were they
concentrating troops how many troops
were they moving this is Thomas payone
he's an exhibit curator at the National
Air and Space Museum in Washington DC
AKA a spy balloon expert that technology
that idea did continue and especially
leading up to World War one where pretty
much all of the combatants on both sides
used observation balloons these balloons
were linked to the ground by telephone
wires which allowed them to direct
artillery in real time they became
highly prized to be shot down also as a
result became very heavily protected
both sides tended to ring their
observation balloon wounds with multiple
anti-aircraft gun positions they often
would have Fighters that were located
nearby to be sent up to protect them if
enemy planes were coming to attack
bringing death to some 5 000 men each
day
rigid airships commonly referred to as
dirigibles or Zeppelins were introduced
as a weapon of war in World War one they
were powered by engines but steered with
elevators and Rudders these stretched
over 500 feet long and could carry
around 20 people their equipment machine
guns and up to two tons of bombs in
World War II the U.S Navy Unleashed a
new weapon for anti-submarine Warfare
the k-ship the blimp Patrol death to
submarines they looked like a blimp and
they had a large control car underneath
and what these case ships did was they
helped alert the convoys to any enemy
submarine that may be operating in the
area and although they did have some
weapons on them they mainly were used to
help call in reinforcements they would
call in other ships ship sinkings have
reached an all-time low and the Navy
salutes its blimps up to this point most
U.S spy balloons were not high altitude
generally when people say high altitude
you're talking about the stratosphere
most of the balloons we're talking about
especially during the Civil War and
World War one they flew no higher than
2000 feet it wasn't until after World
War II that the U.S began exploring high
altitude spy balloons during the Cold
War the U.S military launched a series
of large-scale missions in which
balloons carrying cameras floated over
Soviet territory and when the U.S sent
troops to Iraq and Afghanistan in this
Century it brought balloons loaded with
video cameras sensors and thermal
imaging capabilities to watch over
remote bases they could send these up
and have surveillance 24 7 with these
they could be used to monitor critical
Road intersections and also monitor
areas to ensure that nobody was say
planting IEDs or setting up for an
attack today the U.S Customs and Border
Patrol uses surveillance balloons to
monitor the southern border but with
more advanced technology like planes and
satellites why still use balloons the
long loader time that balloons offer
um have been kind of one of their top
benefits throughout the ages satellites
because they are in orbit you have
shorter Windows of time that you can use
their sensors on them over a specific
area once it passes over you have to
wait for it to kind of come back around
balloons are also less reliant on fuel
than aircraft these advantages help
explain why the Pentagon has shifted to
increased funding for high altitude
Inflatables according to a national
security expert the latest high-tech
balloons have the potential to track
Hypersonic weapons which are being
developed by China and Russia
foreign